hello has incredible enemy variety in
terms of like in terms of the way in
which you can fight very yeah like the
weapons playing to that as well this I
feel like because they've had to like
homogenized this in a way because
ultimately when you make any game like
this it is connected with a bunch of
people and has character customization
then you were allowing people to do
whatever they want in terms of weapons
so you cannot design enemies so they
cannot be killed except for one
particular way like it restricts you way
more in design so like in Halo they know
that people are gonna have this weapon
this weapon and this weapon when they're
going into this fight and that we've
already taught an x y&z like a gameplay
mechanic where's the problem with
something like this because it's so
open-ended they can't be that specific
which means that like the encounters
like are just homogeneous by their very
nature so like that's like that's fine
like there's nothing there's nothing bad
about that like you could be kind of
kind of can't do that apples apples
comparison and people are going to
because obviously it's a Bungie game but
of course this is way more like like
portal and suffer the same thing it's
it's not something that's inherently bad
with the game it's just something that
me personally when I play first-person
shooters it just it irritates me bitter
it does engage me I guess well I'd say
like there are certain moments where
like you're kind of asked to to realize
what weapon you need to bring in like
you know like for instance those kind of
zombie like guys it's like you're not
you're not busting a sniper rifle like
you get your switch to tour shotgun but
it's more like yeah that's that's more
like you're just base level of like how
to play first-person shooters it's like
don't bring a pistol to a fight with a
would like a bunch of do you know you
spray when you're when you're playing a
bunch of guys use like an AoE Wow in a
certain situation or a grenade you just
die I just oh yeah let's not go over
those those guys those guys are
straight-up question marks
oh god there's two dudes though like
yeah oh yeah okay that's a one-shot it
so you get question Park dude yep oh is
that with us yes it'll eyes on top we're
definitely question marks we don't want
to go to there but I'll crap did I just
lose my bounty situation I think I've
worked a bounty
there was an experience thing yep oh
well
so what's the plan just respawn or we're
going to the right though uh yeah we're
gonna go to the right those guys up
there up here these dudes are question
marks and if they're question marks you
don't you don't mess with them are we
playing within our proper level not
really higher lower we're playing under
so we're er under level this is a very
hard question okay somewhere so these
guys are 13 here we go cuz some folks in
the Java talking about hair like perhaps
were we're playing like easy levels or
whatever like it's not the difficulty
for me as well it's not about the level
like stop being difficult because it's a
grind and stop being difficult because
you have to use tactics are two totally
different things
so regardless of even if we're like in
the wrong level like if it's hard
because I have to stand behind a [ __ ]
wall and get my health to like respawn
over and over and over again like that's
not the type of difficulty I'm looking
for it's like outsmarting people is the
type of diffic in the moment like which
games like Halo and like half-life for
instances is it game that like a lot of
people who don't like us
say it's quite boring or whatnot but
like the the nuance in that is that sort
of moment-to-moment trying to figure out
what weapon to use in what situation
welcome the variety within like the
actual AI themselves yeah so the
question then for me is what is uh
there's some spirit bloom over here if
you guys want bloom once in a while um
the question for me then is like okay so
you know halo restricts what weapons you
have generally by only having finite
types of ammo you basically don't don't
have you know your weapon is not
guaranteed to have ammo as unless you're
like you know it's the assault rifle
when you're fighting with a lot
alongside Marines you'll have them oh
yeah you know elites you'll have those
oh the question are you in there hey
gimme I got you with this one you know
your your weapon variety there's they're
sort of not exercising control over that
because you can
have all types of weapon variety Oh
minotaurs but you know - it - so what is
the then the difference is it is it does
it depend on your play style like if I'm
rushing in more I'm challenging myself
to like avoid these dudes but are they
the kind of dudes that like because they
have area attacks are just gonna destroy
me anyways I mean that wasn't good
maneuvering on my part where I just died
but there is a way to play a game like
halo where you are pushing it you are
you are overextending yourself and
making that daring maneuver and because
it's awesome because or because you know
you realize you're gonna have to knock
out these you're gonna have to force the
balance of combat to come back in your
favor by making some kind of bold move
it doesn't I feel like the reason that
this doesn't really the reason why this
combat feels doesn't feel that way to me
is kind of I feel to be it's because of
those area attacks it's because you know
that feel like dodging you know you can
dodge stuff but if the dudes are doing
these smash attacks these big area
damage is coming for you yeah this
Minotaur I have got he's got me in his
sights
oh we got him does not do much you know
like the kind of Oh is my power which is
why all the health came off just get you
think we're he suddenly he's the second
you know I feel like there's
like a nature of the enemy's attacks
might be one consideration because a lot
of them high-powered dudes in this their
high-powered because their tax have big
splash damage but in Halo the attacks
are all just about quantity of
projectile and avoid you know the only
there's only a few enemies that really
do have that kind of Splash Damage that
will mess you up really badly so I guess
that allows you to sort of be a little
more playful with dodging their shots
maybe yeah I'd like to me it's it's like
we're using friggin assault rifles and
pistols the guts
yeah it's and the guys were facing like
look at these guys they are literally
hambling towards me shooting and when
the like turtle legs like it's like it's
the difference between a ones who flank
or it's just the way these games are
designed it's nothing you know it's I
don't know why it's okay it's the differ
it's the difference between fighting
waves of stuff and fighting like smaller
amounts that are that are actually
working together or like display some
sort of rioting like it's just a Devore
maybe in a more controlled kind of these
guys are [ __ ] hard yet that we might
we might be over yeah there's like three
levels above me anyway made so yeah
we're not leveling that hard so like
literally these
where you guys are all right let's unite
our clans will take one one concerted
push into it and then maybe go do
something else so it is this way we do
have to go that way through there you
guys like just from a really like blue
sky first-person design this perspective
just a Matic compare this game with
something like beef like just I know
it's like it's not Apple stop opposed by
any [ __ ] means but just to like to to
think about it higher like enemy
encounters can be in first-person
shooters and how different this is this
is a game which is about like it's more
not the specific because or we all try
to kill this one minutes are he's
charging me oh you cut it another one
out do these guys right oh damn warping
around the place
so we encounter a situation like this
right we're we're not very well level
relative to these guys but you know we
can take them down is it you know so
then it becomes our choice whether we
want to keep sort of yeah we should we
shouldn't be doing this like this is the
game telling us not to be here yeah
right and so my game communicates that
well so yeah it's how many like level at
base we should we should enough we
should probably get out of here and do
it from education it's like wait you are
this is the start as well so oh yeah
that's true don't worry guys I stabbed
him in the butt we're gonna pretty sure
he's in that now I'm not sure if he has
a butt but don't be you like that's
probably also
now this is my highest damage I got it
yeah we almost camera stab them in the
garage terrible there we go revived
[Music]